the chichi science show clips
and so you mentioned the human clinical
trials and so i believe that there is in
the works released in process a human
clinical trial at singapore looking at
the effects of akg on a variety of
different aging biomarkers and so um
could you tell me a bit more about the
clinical trial where you're currently at
and what different markers are you
trying to look at
yeah there are two clinical studies that
are that are
sort of in process
one is using the rejuvent product by the
company and so that's a
calcium akg stain release plus
a vitamin for men it's vitamin name for
women it's vitamin d
that's what the product has and uh
that's a
six month clinical study people 45 to 65
years old it's nearly finished and i
think it'll be finished in the next
three months
and we'll be able to start to really
look at the data we're looking at
methylation clock
as well as a number of clinical markers
inflammatory markers metabolic markers
etc
and we're really hopeful that we'll see
some beneficial effects on biologic
aging now we already know that the um
that study is being conducted at indiana
university actually we already know that
people that buy the product we they can
buy a methylation test at the beginning
and they do a test four to six months
later
and we are seeing a reversal of biologic
age in those individuals but that's not
a clinically controlled study i mean
it's subject to placebo effects and
everything and so it'll be really
it's great that we're seeing that but we
want to see how much of that translates
through to the
you know controlled clinical study and
then in
uh singapore what we're doing is a whole
series
right now we're doing cross-sectional
measures of biologic aging so we have
300 individuals and we're measuring
probably 10 different things that
address biologic age and we want to
begin to understand which of those work
in singapore ethnicities
but also
to see how they relate to each other so
if the methylation clock says you're old
you know we have another clock from 3d
facial reconstruction does that say
you're old as well
because i don't want to spend
five thousand dollars to measure aging i
want to spend 200 but i'm not sure any
one clock is sufficient either so we
need to know where the overlap is
where the uniqueness is in these clocks
and then the next then we're going to be
doing this a whole series of
interventions one of which is the
sustain release calcium alpha
ketoglutarate without the vitamins
because here i want to get more toward
mechanism and not have the complicating
factor of the vitamins but we'll also
test a number of other supplements and
lifestyle interventions and the goal is
really to
figure out which interventions work the
best in humans because i don't think
anybody really knows the answer to that
yet and
also to figure out which ones work and
which people maybe some interventions
work better in males or females or
or maybe things some people some things
don't work in smokers etc we want to
start to personalize these interventions
so that we can have a better better
efficacy
that sounds really exciting so when
these results come out what would you
regard as being i don't know like
positive results and given the if there
are positive results what would you do
with that information in terms of what
do you hope to do in terms of subsequent
trials or investigations
yeah i think that um
well there have been a couple studies
already there was a recent study on
exercise and lifestyle interventions
that showed that
using a methylation clock they could
reverse aging by three years i think
with a with a short enriched
[Music]
and there was a previous study looking
at three different
uh
taking three different small molecules
where nine people did it could reverse
biologic age by a couple years
those are really small studies they're
not controlled very well however i think
they're important because they're
suggesting
that it might be possible to reverse
aging at least to some degree
um you know i'm not i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna say that david beckham's gonna
be on the soccer field again but
but it may be that you know that i think
a lot of people thought you could slow
the process but if you slow the process
even with the biomarkers it's a really
hard thing to measure because you know
over six months they don't change that
much
if you can actually reverse them
even by you know two three five years
uh
that's a really exciting finding that's
what these studies are suggesting and
what we need to do now is go back and do
really controlled studies to validate
that
and maybe it is possible to reverse
aging to some degree i think that would
be i think
when i started in the field you know a
lot of people said you'll never modify
aging is too complex
and if you do you'll just slow it down
you'll never reverse it
and now i think most people are saying
it's pop
it's possible to slow aging
but i don't know if you'll be able to
reverse it so i mean we're making
progress i don't know where the end
point is but i'm ex even if we can
extend healthspan by five years
in the population that's a huge economic
and quality of life benefits so i think
we can set that goal first
even if we just get there we've already
done a lot
um
you know we're going to have to do these
studies are relatively small 120 people
or so six month interventions people 45
to 65
if they show really
positive data then one of the things
we'll have to do is to do bigger studies
to validate and to get more personalized
data but you know a lot of what we're
testing is supplements and lifestyles so
we're really looking to partner with
singapore government and other agencies
here to scale things into community
testing
i would really love for everybody when
they hit a certain age to get their
biologic age measure and if something as
simple as a 3d facial reconstruction
works which is totally non-invasive you
could imagine that being done when you
go to get your id renewed right so um uh
i'm hopeful that we can really implement
some of these things and uh start to
have an effect and singapore is an ideal
testing ground for that huge problem
with aging here
um because uh you know it's a small
island there's not the reproductive rate
is extremely low and
people live a long time so the you know
it's it's almost like japan in terms of
the percentage of people over the age of
65 a little bit behind but catching up
and so this is a great place to see if
we can really do something about it